OVER THE 9 P.M. HOUR.
>> Sean: THANKS AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
>> AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE
ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
DAY 73.
>> Sean: WE WON'T GIVE UP
THINKING ABOUT AND PRAYING FOR
AND REMINDING ALL OF THE COUNTRY
THAT IT'S NOW 73 DAYS.
TONIGHT THE OFFICIAL NUMBER OF
AMERICANS STILL TRAPPED IN
AFGHANISTAN CONTINUES TO RISE.
FIRST IT WAS THEY TOLD US UNDER
100.
THEN A COUPLE OF HUNDRED.
NOW GETTING CLOSER TO 1,000
TONIGHT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T KNOW HOW
MANY AMERICANS THAT JOE BIDEN
LEFT BEHIND.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
THOUSANDS OF GREEN CARD HOLDERS
HE ABANDONED AND THEIR FAMILIES.
DAY 73.
THIS IS STILL A COMPLETE
DISASTER.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF ISIS OR
A TERROR GROUP GETS AHOLD OF
THESE AMERICANS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEIR FUTURE
WILL HOLD FOR THEM?
ACCORDING TO ONE TOP PENTAGON
OFFICIAL, ISIS-K COULD HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO ATTACK THE U.S. IN
6 TO 12 MONTHS.
GUESS WHAT?
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CARE.
HE TURNED THE PAGE LIKE IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
THE MEDIA MOB TURNED THE PAGE
WITH HIM WANT TONIGHT JOE IS
A FEW MILES AWAY FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE, HE IS IN NORTHERN
VIRGINIA COME PAINING FOR
LONG-TIME CLINTON HACK TERRY
MCAULIFFE -- TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AM JOE BIDEN.
I AM JILL BIDEN'S HUSBAND.
THE REASON I AM HERE TONIGHT IS
MY WIFE JILL TEACHES FULL-TIME
AT THE VIRGINIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> AND TERRY MCAULIFFE WILL BE
HER BOSS.
TO WIN THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION
HE EMBRACED DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IT WILL BE DEDICATED TO THE
PASSENGER RAIL AND [INAUDIBLE].
IT'S A BIG GAME CHANGER.
VOTE, VOTE, VOTE.
>> Sean: KIND OF JOE TO DEDICATE
HIS TIME AND ENERGY TO THE
MCAULIFFE CAMPAIGN.
NOT OFTEN HE GETS AWAY FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE THIS LATE AT NIGHT.
PROBABLY TOOK A LONG NAP TO
CAMPAIGN FOR TERRY MCAULIFFE WHO
ANNOUNCED THAT JOE'S HORRIBLE
PERFORMANCE IN OFFICE WAS
DRAGGING HIM DOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE GOT TO GET DEMOCRATS OUT
TO VOTE.
WE ARE FACING A LOT OF HEAD
WINDS FROM WASHINGTON.
THE PRESIDENT IS UNPOPULAR TODAY
IN VIRGINIA.
WE HAVE TO PLOW THROUGH.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN IS UNPOPULAR.
AFTER A SERIES OF MASSIVE
SELF-INFLICTED CRISES HIS
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE IN THE
MID-30s AND WITH THE OPPONENT
GLENN YOUNGKIN PICKING UP
MOMENTUM, DESPERATE TIMES CALL
FOR DESPERATE MEASURES.
TERRY MCAULIFFE, EVERYTHING JOE
BIDEN TOUCHES IMPLODES.
AFGHANISTAN COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED AND THE BORDER.
HIS HANDLING OF COVID-19.
MORE DEAD AMERICANS IN 2021 THAN
THIS 2020.
THE ECONOMY, BIDEN INFLATION AND
GAS PRICES AND FOREIGN POLICY
AND CHINA AND IRAN AND NORTH
KOREA AND RUSSIA.
HE COULD NOT NEGOTIATE
A SUBMARINE DEAL WITH AUSTRALIA
WITHOUT CAUSING A CRISIS.
THIS SEAMS LIKE A LAST-MINUTE
HAIL MAR